buonasera a tutti
allora mi dispiace solamente che non
avete un calice di vino in mano perché
sarebbe la cosa fondamentale a quest'ora
sicuramente questa piccola presentazione
che ho voluto dedicare per questo speech
di oggi è una cosa scientifica quindi la
premessa che il nostro palato è uguale
per tutti voi vedete questi grandissimi
somellier in televisione
io evito di fare questa cosa che tolgono
a volte conigli dal cappello che
significa significa che vi parlano che
ne so di legno di sandalo di legno di
cedro di curcuma di cumino e magari
nessuno di voi ha mai annusato queste
cose mi trovo spesso e volentieri a
trovarmi davanti a del pubblico a fare
delle presentazioni di vino con un
pubblico che potenzialmente non ha
un'istruzione per poter capire le
sfaccettature sia di sensoriali che
gustative di quello che riguarda il vino
voi pensate 100 persone che hanno
lavorato in banca arrivano una sera col
miglior azione del mondo a fare una
degustazione e io inizia a sentire
facilità tannino oppure nissa parlare di
gomma di persistenza quindi c'è una
chiave di lettura molto divertente che è
quello che è l'innovazione la
presentazione di oggi si chiama
innovazione quindi dimenticatevi quello
che avete visto fino ad ora ora farò
spengere le luci e iniziamo in un
percorso sensoriale tipo un centro
benessere del gusto un modo diverso di
parlare di vino utilizzando i colori
utilizzando le linee e utilizzando la
musica
se vuoi spendere lui sì
perfetto pensate al colore verde che
cosa vi dona il colore verde nella vita
in questo momento voi avete una sala è
piena dei bicchieri di vino
io faccio spegnere le luci e voi
prendete il colore verde cosa succede
quando c'è il semaforo verde non mi dite
che passate che vi fermate perché
semaforo verde lasciapassare
il verde è il colore che viene associato
al biologico
pensate quello che la nostra vita quando
si dice una personalità in erba il verde
e la freschezza il verde all'acidità
quindi stasera vi ha servito una
bollicina voi in questo momento avete
una bollicina in mano agli inizi a
parlare del vino vi faccio il vin e
verde tutta la sala inizia a ridere
perché rigorosamente una bollicina
rigorosamente questo colore dorato però
rispecchia quello che è il colore verde
i colori sono fondamentali perché hanno
un significato c'è un vocabolario dei
colori e da lì li possiamo associare a
quello che è il vino quindi il verde
viene associato al colore della natura
simbolo dell'ulivo
immaginatevi un albero di arancio il
percorso della vita inizia verde e
finisce rosso quando pensate al verde
piazzata la freschezza l'associate
all'acidità ed associata era
inesperienza quello che anche vini
bianchi danno perché sono dei vini
bianchi magari che vanno bevuti subito e
questo è fondamentale quando pensate al
palato che ha disegnato con quattro
sensazioni per tutte uguali
dovete pensare che queste sensazioni che
avete in bocca sono per tutti uguali
quindi un vino bianco che ha freschezza
è un insieme di punti che sappiamo dove
inizia e dove finisce quindi se noi
descriviamo questo vino a una persona
che non sa niente di vino con il verde e
con una linea gustativa diritta che è
quello che fa l'acidità nel palazzo e
poi magari abbiniamo un brano musicale
tipo una musica elettrica perché il vino
bianco vivrà questo è quello che possono
provare le persone e che possono
riscoprire con delle cose che comunque
sono parte della nostra vita parte nella
sua vita perché abbiamo la musica
abbiamo le linee e abbiamo i colori che
vengono associati a quello che abbiamo
nella vita
vi faccio continuare a giocare il rosso
facile dire un vino rosso
cosa vi do nel rosso nella vita
sensualità calore
io lo trovo pericoloso lo trovo morbido
però pensiamo al colore precedente che
era il verde e pensiamo al rosso da una
parte la maturità e la dolcezza
dall'altra parte la freschezza quindi a
parte casse ma foro il rosso ci si ferma
qualche volta si passa però in generale
si ferma quindi un segnale di pericolo
come il primo bicchiere di vino rosso se
magari si fa bere molto bene la maturità
quando meglio un vino rosso senti la
maturità del frutto nel naso e quando
vedi il colore rosso la socia subito la
maturità è usato per evidenziare se vuoi
in un contratto avete la scritta firma
il rosso la prima passa che vedete
quella quindi attrae l'attenzione come
un bel bicchiere di vino rosso toscano
il rosso è il colore del sangue il rosso
viene associato anche a tutto quello che
riguarda la matematica quindi molto
carnale
quando vai assaggiate questo vino rosso
in maniera diciamo teorica però ancora
una volta la sale spenta voi avete un
bicchiere di vino rosso davanti e vedete
questo colore rosso parliamo di linee
gustative il rosso è associato alla
sfera gustativa da piccoli giocavate con
le biglie ogni miglia che avete messo in
bocca se si riprovate ora da ogni parte
del vostro palato che tocca spingendo da
quella lingua nella parte superiore non
troverà resistenza e questa è la
rotondità gustativa se lo fate con un
dado o con un triangolo è totalmente
differente
vedete che gli angoli creano un gioco
differente e se dobbiamo associare al
rosso una musica logicamente il rosso
che è ematico il rosso che è sensuale il
rosso che è il calore si sposerebbe bene
con quello che riguarda magari un tango
o una musica molto calda molto
avvolgente c'è un vocabolario per queste
cose quindi se il vocabolario dei colori
che si aiuta a entrare nella mente della
gente provando a parlare delle cose
potrebbe essere associato al vino come
tante altre cose e ora vi voglio
stimolare con
un'altra cosa pensate a un vino di 20
anni facciamo siamo in toscana brunello
di montalcino di 20 anni
brunel montalcino di 20 anni è blu e
tutta la sala di magra vita perché il
brunello blu che cosa succede quando
vedete il mare il cielo
la prima cosa che vedete l'inizio e non
vedete la fine i blu è un colore
classico sicuramente non avete mai visto
un politico andare in parlamento con la
giacca gialla può succedere questo solo
in italia però principalmente non
dovrebbe essere il blu è il colore
classico è un colore che dà profondità è
un colore che leva l'appetito
perché quando ti trovi davanti a un
grandissimo vino rosso l'attenzione va
subito sul vino e perde l'attenzione su
quello che è il nostro piatto per andare
in abbinamento il blu è un colore che
per essere classico ha bisogno di tante
componenti
ci dona freschezza ci dà una sobrietà ma
ci dona anche una lunghezza visiva
classico è anche un brunello di
montalcino di vent'anni fatto da 100 per
100 sangiovese
voi pensate ora di assaggiarlo e come vi
entrano bocca questo sangiovese è
praticamente un quadrato gustativo la
nostra poca assaggia assente solo
quattro cose quello che è l'acidità la
freschezza la sapidità e tutto quello
che ha l'amaro in quattro punti
differenti
se voi mettete del cotone nel naso
questo ci fecero a tutti quindi quando
prendete un dado da gioco veramente da
in bocca e lo spinge te con la lingua
nella parte superiore sentirete che la
perfezione i quattro angoli questa tv mi
toccano la lingua e la parte superiore
del palato il brano musicale che deve
essere abbinato al blu oppure al dado al
quadrato che cosa sarebbe per voi cosa
ci potesse trovare in questo abbinamento
musicale
l'abbinamento musicale sicuramente fatto
da un pezzo di musica classica perse di
musica classica perché ogni strumento in
un grande vino è fondamentale
quindi dal violoncello la viola il
contrabbasso per rendere grande lo
spettro del vino
questo è un linguaggio che si può
utilizzare nel momento in cui trovi
delle persone un po più difficile quando
non abbiamo un bicchiere di vino davanti
a quest'ora ci starebbe anche bene però
può essere utilizzato perché la gente
vive questi colori vivi queste emozioni
vive le forme geometriche e durante il
brano musicale va a finire il suo
bicchiere di vino senza essere poi
suggestionato da in mille discorsi che
facciamo noi sono migliaia che a volte
veramente sembriamo dei grandissimi
maghi grazie